la imparable temporada de lluvias en
Colombia sigue cobrando vidas un
deslizamiento de tierra en el
departamento colombiano de risaralda
mató a decenas de personas después que
el autobús en el que se desplazaban
quedara sepultado el bus se encontraba
sepultado a unos dos metros bajo tierra
Así mismo llevaba un total de 37
personas incluido el conductor y su
ayudante de las cuales fallecieron 34
entre los cuales se encuentran 8 menores
al parecer otros vehículos particulares
también quedaron bajo tierra El
deslizamiento se produjo el domingo en
una vía que comunica al centro con el
occidente del país según las autoridades
el terreno se encontraba fuertemente
afectado luego de varios días de lluvias
lo cual complicó las labores de rescate
que ya terminaron debido a que se trata
de una zona montañosa y un terreno
inestable desde agosto del 2020 Colombia
ha sufrido los estragos del fenómeno de
la niña dejando tras su paso más del 60%
de los municipios afectados los
pronósticos estiman que el fen se
mantendrá hasta por lo menos febrero del
2023 queremos declarar nuestra alerta
máxima en todo el territorio por esta
ola invernal que ha traído tanto daño
material y también en vidas como la que
acaba de ocurrir la unidad nacional para
la gestión del riesgo de desastres instó
a los habitantes de la zona abandonar
sus hogares ya que se podrían presentar
nuevos deslizamientos mientras las
lluvias siguen afectando todo el país